my speculation family making home in
jube Paducah like a job she not what
have shown responsive Frances far-right
National Front party only one five
percent of the vote in Paris but Medina
lupins pledged to keep France for the
French is a message that resonates in
rural communities where people have felt
neglected for decades in France like in
Trump's America the rift between the
bustling cities and dying countryside is
transforming the political map how did
one small formerly left-wing village
fall into the arms of the far-right I'm
here in vazhi which is a small village
in Burgundy that once was a left-wing
stronghold but today has been completely
abandoned but for the majority of people
who remain they believe that only Mahim
lepen can bring back life to the
countryside boxzy has been turned into a
ghost town by a failing economy a lack
of jobs and an aging population mark the
butcher is one of the people struggling
to keep the community alive Rajesh apipa
chiku vigil yokota wiki really clicked
on the presumptive see these areas I
need to pick up
yes kiss c'mere generatio Soho le pas de
la nouvelle mo boku mo cuishle mo coup
d'etat by people here have been
suffering from massive unemployment for
decades the villages aging population
has watched as small industries in
manufacturing and textiles disappeared
just like its youth when it was a kids
there are much more people here and now
everyone is leaving him why no jobs no
but not everyone leaves and among those
who stayed behind more than 30 percent
of them voted for the National Front and
more young people are joining the party
than ever before fusion is realistic
Adira whoa lassie submission territoire
semicolon ever since a paveed Okanagan
depuis bohemian 8fa concat Manali
companion Oh Georgie to tal poofy Deegan
me couple a days ago my ratio is a tool
accompany LEP TV - Delaney ago sunroom
only grows we it's places like this in
France that have lost their businesses
and their residents highlighting the
growing division between the cities and
the countryside between the affluent and
those who've been left behind some years
ago I mean they all voted for our lawns
and he didn't change anything that's a
problem
the survey clearly abou could easily see
p.m. - a puzzle a mall open see I were
to do deep
[Music]
it used to be that this town voted left
that there were young people here who
were progressive but now it's voting
marine lepen on the phone yes or not do
you think she's racist yes do you think
the people here who voted for her think
she's racist most of them no do you
think they're racist no don't feel so
the National Front more than doubled its
vote here in the last regional elections
and it's here in Burgundy that the pan
is hoping to make her biggest gains
Herald is running as a candidate for the
National Front in the upcoming elections
and he believes that even in a town with
no immigrants foreigners are to blame
for the town's problems do you think
immigration is the reason why a town
like Varzi is struggling or a bishop but
what is immigration have to do with
bugsy because everyone we speak to says
there's no immigrants in bugsy Banco oh
yeah they don't want to do the force on
a video check with local a new war zone
getting go ignore sounds more the
population living on we know if you
don't want the evacuation successive
notional short wonders this is necessity
if you knew what is on the vivo Electra
tourism in the park on your substrate or
a vehicle which you call the all of the
Moscone desires for another Hungary
Socrates you say you know foster my
despair snippin kikyo-san Eastern key
energy about 10% of France's population
is Muslim
in 2010 lepen cast their mere presence
in the country as an occupation a remark
that brought on court charges of
inciting religious hatred but aren't
there French people who have lived here
for 200
who are Muslim who maybe one aware the
hijab in school mrs. satty civically
occupation it's an occupation we're just
in the umbilical yellow knee room with
the wondering about our auto new on the
whole issues was not that well sis sis
swingers secondly our legacy epidural a
mid-career teachers were a non-circular
suspected Paniagua
wrong on our career especially teachers
came at no donors at Rikers a felony on
cozy and much like in the u.s. people
here tell us they've been neglected by
the government forgotten by all
politicians and crushed by globalization
which is why people here are so
desperate for radical change the present
issues that will be visual family be
magnetically radiates and is Africa
reallocation resume our national for
buscemi also issue no Priya to mushroom
with the commissioner and just to give
you a sense of how hard life is here the
main source of income for this village
is this retirement home where people
literally come to die wanted kick movie
we heard Navi ronamoon best defender
make is Facundo to Clara shu koukin
sweetie missile rocket body Maternity
[Music]
hey I'm a jeopardy here in Paris fans
we're just like in the US these
presidential elections are all about
fear when faced with the choice between
a capitalist banker McCaul the far-right
leader machine the young people who
can't find jobs who are disillusioned
who don't trust the government well they
tell us they're not voting so don't miss
our next video all about that